wir haben vor einigen jahren die
wehrpflicht in deutschland ausgesetzt
dieser schritt war richtig nur 15
prozent damals des jahrgangs wurden noch
bezogen man konnte fast googeln was man
dem kreiswehrersatzamt gesagt hat damit
man nicht zur bundeswehr gehen sollte
oder wollte oder musste und in dieser
phase hätte man eigentlich eine debatte
an fachwissen über ein pflichtjahr für
alle über ein verpflichtendes
gesellschafts jahr so wie ich das nenne
für junge menschen die nach der schule
junge frauen und männer ein jahr lang
bei johanniter rote kreuz bei den
sozialen diensten malteser aber auch bei
der bundeswehr oder bei der feuerwehr
oder im ausland gerne auch bei vereinen
wie müssten dann akkreditiert seien ein
jahr dienst an dieser gesellschaft
absolviert ich halte das für unglaublich
wichtig weil ich glaube in teilen ist
dieses land ja zu einer
selbstverwirklichung
gesellschaft geworden man bestellt nicht
nur bei emerson die produkte sondern
auch beim start man ist sich dessen gar
nicht mehr bewusst dass es in einem
staat auch pflichten gibt und nicht nur
rechte gleichzeitig fehlt es an
debattenkultur in deutschland
deutschland ist zum teil debatten
unfähig in bestimmten bereichen und
deswegen brauchen wir wieder eine
gesellschaft die debattiert und diese
sozialen kompetenzen die müssen wir
wieder vermitteln und deshalb bin ich
für ein verpflichtendes gesellschafts
jahr gleichzeitig tun wir auch noch was
zur für die pflege 6 millionen zu
pflegen da haben wir im jahre 2030 ist
vielen 200.000 fachkräfte und die eine
oder der andere wird vielleicht animiert
durch diesen
gesellschafts dienst dass sie mit der
pflege in verbindung gebracht werden
vielleicht wäre ich nie auf die idee
gekommen diesen beruf auszuüben all das
spricht dafür
also kurz und knapp ich bin für ein
verpflichtendes gesellschafts jahr in
deutschland da habe ich hätte man eine
andere stadt auf was als ich diese haben
aber
habe ich auch insofern beantworte ich
das gerne machen
ich schätze sie sehr als mann der klaren
kante der klaren aussprache ich glaube
so etwas braucht die union und insofern
freue ich mich immer wenn ich ihre sehr
pointierten meinungen insofern als mich
ein bisschen überrascht dass sie diesen
doch relativ alten hut wieder
hervorzaubern denn das ist eine
forderung die von ihrer parteikollegin
angeht kramp karrenbauer schon im jahr
2018 also vor fast vier jahren erhoben
worden ist und die gesagt hat wir
brauchen genau das was sie hier
vorgeschlagen haben passiert ist seitdem
wenig aber wer weiß wenn sie
irgendwann mehr verantwortung haben
vielleicht schaffen sie das ja das dann
entsprechend umzusetzen ich glaube ihnen
geht's aber in wirklichkeit um was ganz
an ihm geht darum irgendwas wieder ins
schaufenster zu stellen was die union
sichtbarer macht nachdem angela merkel
erneut über sie gesprochen die union
doch ziemlich entfernt hat und einer
dieser entfernung war die abschaffung
der wehrpflicht 2011 auch
holterdiepolter bei ebenso in einem
handstreich gemacht von herrn von
guttenberg schlecht vorbereitet wir
wissen dass alle insofern er hatte
seinen nachfolger nachfolgerinnen damit
zu tun die folgen davon abzuarbeiten die
erde unter viel beifall auch von
verschiedenen organen der umgesetzt hat
aber die abschaffung oder sie haben es
richtig formuliert die aussetzung der
wehrpflicht abgeschafft ist sie ja nicht
im jahr 2011 war sicherlich der größte
fehler den man hätte machen können egal
wie der bekannte der befund der
streitkräfte jetzt ist denn man hat
damit ja auch indirekt den zivildienst
abgeschafft und die folgen sehen wir
jetzt knappheit in den pflegeberufen und
dergleichen deswegen bin ich dafür die
wehrpflicht wieder einzusetzen und damit
auch den zivildienst wieder und nicht
mit halbheiten zu agieren sondern nur
für hier und nicht für mädchen naja
vielleicht er will natürlich aber da
sind sie ja de facto oder für ich will
es nun noch breiter ziehen dass auch
vereine die sich einsetzen in
deutschland die müssen natürlich
bestimmte bedingungen eigentlich sei sie
ja gar nichts wissen dieses machen
dieses machen doch bundeswehr auch
bundeswehr auch rote kreuz ist der
beitrag ja in einem punkt haben sie
recht wir haben die frage in der
parteien nie beantwortet seit 2008 10
die wurde nicht zu ende diskutiert die
möchte ich gerne zu ende diskutiert ich
werde mich dafür einsetzen wenn ich die
debatte die lehre ist es auch gut dann
haben wir so entschieden aber ich will
in dieser frage der entscheidung nichts
sagen dass der film haltungen bin ich
dann bedeutet wenn ich verliere ist es
gut wir müssen noch streiten und kämpfen
hat und dann ist es schlecht seite und
streitet jetzt aus dem einzelnen doppel
um 1 höher in johannes wie siehst du das
denn gesellschaftliche sehr gut ich bin
sehr sehr sehr liberal und findet jeder
mensch sollte selber darüber entscheiden
wie er sein leben verbringt und trotzdem
habe ich massives sympathien für diese
idee weil ich glaube der gesellschaft
fehlt ist der linnemann und auch gesagt
ankit der sie zusammenhält es fehlt an
einem gemeinschaftlichen erlebnisse es
fehlt an verständnis dafür dass jeder
für diesen staat auch was tun muss und
ich glaube das wäre gut übrigens auch im
hinblick auf die migration die wir
hinter uns haben auf die migration die
vor uns liegt dass jede hier einmal dazu
verpflichtet wird an der gesellschaft
wirklich teilzuhaben und seinen teil zu
leisten
also ich habe ein anderes
staatsverständnis ich glaube nicht dass
der bürger dienst am staat leisten muss
überhaupt nicht ich war selbst
wehrpflichtiger ich wäre ungern mit mir
selbst in eine kampfhandlung gezogen
muss ich ganz offen sagen und so wird es
ganz ganz viel anders anderen gehen ich
möchte eigentlich auch nicht dass eine
großmutter die pflegebedürftige es
beispielsweise oder ein großvater oder
eine mutter oder ein vater von jemandem
gepflegt wird er darauf keine lust hat
der es machen muss weil der staat sagt
so du kannst ja außerdem bundeswehr
jugendherberge oder pflegedienst
überhaupt nicht und wenn wir schon bei
der frage sind was kann man für die
gesellschaft leisten dann würde ich
sagen direkt nach der schule eine lehre
in der ausbildung ins studium und danach
richtig den job machen auf den man lust
hat denn dann ist der dienst an der
gesellschaft wenn es mal so bezeichnen
will der allergrößte also ich leiste am
meisten für die gesellschaft einen job
der mir spaß macht und nicht zu dem ich
die zwei jahren da könnt ihr das
gesellschaft sehr helfen zum beispiel
habe ich den fall in meinem
freundeskreis die hier war wollte
marketing kauffrau werbekauffrau hatte
auch schon die ausbildung der zeit dann
hat sie sich noch von fsj unterschieden
entschieden das freiwillige soziale jahr
die macht jetzt gerade psychologie zu
ende und möchte später in einer
psychiatrie arbeiten mit den menschen
wie gesagt ohne das freiwillige soziale
jahr hätte sie niemals gemerkt dass sie
der soziale berufe sowie gut ist und ich
muss sagen mir hätte so ein gesellschaft
ja echt nicht geschadet also ich bin
dabei herr linnemann und ich sehe das
auch ähnlich
freiwilliges soziales jahr ist doch gut
es ist jedem unbenommen
so sagen doch die debattenkultur das
erleben wir doch in ihren sendungen die
ist doch abhanden gekommen da sind
menschen den ganzen tag ein echo kam als
nur in facebook wo die eigene meinung
widergespiegelt wird wir brauchen eine
kultur in deutschland wo es eine these
gibt eine antithese und synthese warum
sie das den alten fähigkeit die bekomme
ich doch durch dies aber die bekomme ich
wenn ich jetzt und ich sage es ganz gut
im maschinenraum auf einer korvette
sitze und da man meinen wehrdienst
ableistete oder ich damals am funkgerät
stehe da hab ich doch keine
debattenkultur ich habe auch keine
debatten werden also so einfach kann man
sich das mit der bundeswehr ja nicht
machen auch erstmal zu deinem ersten
argument herr lindemann hat ja nicht nur
gesprochen von dem trainer der keine
lust zu hause und er hat von einer
breiten palette vom bürgerlichen oder
sozialen engagement gesprochen denn
genau es gab zu unterschiedliche
möglichkeit außerdem du weißt bei der
bundeswehr gehört auch sowas dazu die
staatsbürgerliche unterrichten und er
gleicht also dinge die man zusätzlich
noch bekommt und den gedanken von einem
mann zu sagen du hast mir auf wir hatten
2015 mit einer million keiner weise ist
ja genau wie viele flüchtlinge die zu
uns gekommen sind gott sei dank sagt
nina schenk was uns bereichen aber
natürlich wäre es gut wenn alle ein
gemeinschaftserlebnis hatten oder hätten
die dann auch entsprechend dann sich in
solchen umgebungen dann auch
verpflichten müssen für deutschland
etwas gutes zu tun